bonsoir à tous l'engagement
ah sacré sujet a sacré ce sujet parce
qu'on ne peut pas accompagner les
transformations des limitations sont se
poser la vraie question l'engagement
je vais essayer ce soir l'espace de
quelques minutes de démystifier vous
donner quelques clés décodage vous
éclairer sur ce qu'on entend par
engagement professionnel
cette fameuse mise en jeu de soi pour
une performance collective
alors d'abord on a posé le cadre comme
dans une démarche de coaching
l'engagement va avoir plusieurs pré
requis d'abord on est dans la liberté
d'expression et on est dans le processus
décisionnel
les personnes sont volontaires elles
sont effectivement mobilisés
elles appartiennent à une organisation
elles sont prêtes à prendre des risques
et à partir de là elles sont prêtes à
être en mouvement
on ne peut pas être engagée si on est
simple spectateur on ne peut pas
embarquer effectivement une organisation
si on n'est pas dans une action
collective
jusque là vous allez me dire tout va
très bien sauf que engagement quand on
fait des recherches
quand on va voir côté anglo-saxon
engaged là il nous donne quelques clés
nouvelle dans le cas d'une étude qui a
été faite par right management qui est
une filiale de manpower appui à
l'harvard business review on a fait une
étude il ya quelques années qui est
toujours d'actualité auprès de presque
trente mille personnes
c'est ce qu'on appelle le gala depuis 12
ça a été un questionnaire qui a permis
d'identifier effectivement comment les
personnes engagées et quel était leur
degré d'engagement multi-secteurs
international cas ce pays est plus
plusieurs effectivement continents
concernés
donc là on va se mettre en lunettes 3d
parce qu'effectivement vous allez voir
que dans l'engagement on n'est pas dans
le fameux engagement l'implication on
n'est pas que dans la satisfaction je
suis content de mon job où je suis
content l'organisation on va devoir
effectivement travaillé sur deux leviers
je ne peut être engagée c'est que si je
le suis auprès de l'organisation et dans
le cadre de mon métier ça c'est un pré
requis super important je ne peux
effectivement ne pas être que dans
l'application
si je ne suis pas satisfait fier et je
fais la promotion à la fois de mon
métier et de l'organisation pour
laquelle je travaille donc là
effectivement on commence effectivement
à se dire que les éléments d'engagement
vont avoir des leviers d ailleurs
différents
je vous partage est une matrice qui est
très éclairante sur effectivement ce qui
se passe dans toutes les sociétés
d'aujourd'hui
le principe est le suivant on a donc
notre psy c'est notre ordonnée avec
l'engagement du métier et l'engagement
effectivement vis-à-vis de
l'organisation partir de là on va mettre
un cadran qui va poser l'implication
collective ou l'implication individuelle
et sa relation visées du changement
clair on est dans un format simple
d'ailleurs quatre types de populations
qu'à typologique on a les stars les
stars ce sont effectivement les
performeurs c'est ce qu'ils vont non
seulement considérer qu'ils sont engagés
dans leur métier ils sont satisfaits
promoteur fier engagés et impliqués et
qui sont aussi tout à fait aligner avec
leurs organisations
donc le là dessus ils vont être dans un
schéma très actif très activiste très
très engagé très mobilisés après avoir
d'autres populations
on va voir les réservistes et les
électrons libres alors les réservistes
eux se considère un peu comme sort de
fichiers excel
ouais la boîte où je suis l'herbe n'est
pas plus verte ailleurs
je vais pas changer pour changer mais
j'ai l'impression d'être un programme
excellent mutisme de 10% de la capacité
est ce qu'on donne vraiment l'occasion
de faire le job
le métier de pouvoir vraiment mettre à
profit mon appétence et mes compétences
eh bien on à l'autre côté les électrons
libres alors ils s'éclatent dans l'ordre
n'y a pas de débat
leur feuille de route est claire ils
prennent vraiment position de leur
métier et ils sont tout à fait engagé
via effectivement les quatre leviers sur
leur métier par contre est-ce que je
suis dans la meilleure des crémeries
pas sûr et là avec la génération des
millenium il n'y a pas débat
on est dans un contrat donnant donnant
donc tu ne tient pas ses engagements la
boîte ne me plaît pas je zappe je
consomme je change
arrivent les derniers nos fameux
disconnect les déconnecter alors
effectivement on est plutôt dans un
format ou par rapport au référentiel tel
que vous l'avez vu de cette matrice via
les quatre leviers eu son écart à la
fois dans leur engagement métier mais
aussi dans l'engagement vis-à-vis
l'organisation quand on a fait cette
étude au sein du groupe mais je les
oublie aussi l'occasion de le faire dans
des séminaires avec des organisations
avec des abbey tous les gens se sont
auto noté je peux vous assurer que les
résultats étaient quasi les mêmes et
c'est là vous allez être surpris
un support comme celui ci je peux passer
deux jours toute une équipe de
dirigeants pour en discuter parce
qu'effectivement pour apporter pour
accompagner le 3 le changement et la
transformation tout se joue sur le bon
éclairage de cette matrice un tiers des
personnes sondées star presque 15%
effectivement sont plutôt des
réservistes et des électrons libres dit
autrement nous sommes très nombreux dans
cette salle
la moitié d'entre vous d'autres nous
sommes peut être déconnecté ça veut dire
qu'on n'est pas performeur mais c'est à
dire qu'on n'est pas du tout un
malignement et dans les degrés
d'engagement telle qu'on pourrait
vraiment les attendre pour contribuer
d'une manière plus efficiente à
l'organisation alors qu'est ce qu'on
fait c'est disconnect avant de vous
partager un petit peu les solutions
relatifs à ces quatre population sachez
qu'on a fait effectivement cette étude
mondiale
et quand vous voyez cette étude mondiale
vous voyez effectivement qu'on est dans
un format ou là dessus il ya un
engagement qui va distincts selon les
pays
la pondération va varier que je sois
plus tôt côté pays anglo saxons on voit
les us le canada et l'inde qui sont avec
des scores très haut très forte un
engagement et peut-être des pays d'asie
ou au niveau culturel le degré
d'engagement est beaucoup moins visible
mais revenons à notre un autre cadre aux
nôtres matrix rappelez-vous cateau
culation les stars les réservistes les
électrons libres les déconnecter être
dans le triangle centrale c'est-à-dire
star réservistes ou déconnecté
finalement ce n'est pas plus mal
finalement ça a du sens on ne peut pas
être star toute sa vie dans le cas de
certains coaching que j'accompagne
effectivement il ya des collaborateurs
qui sont des stars qui sont très très
engagé qui vont aller vite qu'ils sont
effectivement dans un format de
performance incontestable et parfois
l'organisation a peur peur du burn out
lors de l'explosion en vol et donc notre
rôle de travail etc les stars pour
effectivement à partir de là leur donner
les signaux de reconnaissance les
occasions ne participe à des décisions
stratégiques
mais tout ça dans un cap vitesse dans un
rythme qui est mesuré arrive maintenant
les bleus les fameux réservistes ou
électron libre
qu'est ce qu'on fait avec une des
options ça va être vraiment engager une
conversation avec lui de quoi ont-ils
besoin que l'on manque t-il finalement
qu'est ce qu'il fait qu'il ya où une
partie d'eux-mêmes dans leur engagement
métier aux engagements organisation qui
ne tient pas la route et à partir de là
bas qu'est ce qu'on peut avoir comme
option on les embarque dans des groupes
de travail en transverse
on les mobiles ils ont redéfini leur job
en tout cas on ré aborde on vous redonne
du sens on ré abord les sujets de demain
et nos fameux 50% disconnect que fait
tourner ses dix connect ça s'appelle le
courage managérial
parce qu'à deux approches option numéro
un on arrive à la fin d'un cycle et
c'est pas un gros mot
c'est pas tabou de parler
d'employabilité qu'elles soient internes
ou externes
on peut arriver à la fin d'une spirale à
la fin d'un cycle et à partir de là
remettre vraiment les compteurs à zéro
et avoir cette conversation courageuse
avec le collaborateur
on peut aussi redonner du sens autrement
le challenge et il va falloir poser un
cadre il va falloir bien redéfinir les
rôles et responsabilités mais clairement
on ne peut pas rester avec des personnes
qui sont dix connectés
parce que soient elles sont en arrêts ne
sont plus en mouvement parfois ils
peuvent être toxiques à une organisation
est sabordé le système parfois elles
veulent freiner et ralentir le système
donc il faut être conscient que dans une
orientation pour accompagner les
transformations les mutations
il faut vraiment être en regard de ces
populations quels sont les impacts et
les enjeux l'engagement en quoi ce sujet
est-il fondamentale maintenant que nous
avons la matrice maintenant nous avons
les populations aux têtes
il faut juste avoir à l'esprit quelques
prérequis premièrement en termes
d'enjeux
à partir du moment le leadership la
gouvernance et reconnu l'engagement se
multiplient par deux donc c'est hier
qu'on se retrouve dans un format ou
tiens on est face à une gouvernance une
direction qui donne le cap qui donne du
sens on y croit on la suit ouf
l'engagement x 2 du baromètre social
peuvent être edouard là dessus mais pour
autant quand vous allez voir la suite
des impacts est en jeu il ya d'autres
items qui sont majeurs incontestable et
incontesté pour pouvoir faciliter
engagement
le deuxième c'est plan de carrière je
parle et d'employabilité donner du sens
et une prospective à un collaborateur
c'est une obligation c'est aujourd'hui
un incontournable
les lois aujourd'hui nous aide nous
donne des cadres nous donne des canevas
pour y arriver
mais une chose est sûr c'est qu'à partir
du moment où un plan de carrière est
posé on multiplie par 6 le degré
d'engagement
je sais où je vais on va poser un
calendrier on va poser un format mais en
tout cas la personne a une visibilité et
une prospective de ce qu'elle va devenir
demain l'exercice continu
x 8 tale of management c'est
effectivement notre coeur de métier
c'est celui sur lequel je travaille
depuis plus d'une quinzaine d'années
travaillées sur effectivement ce capital
humain comment peut-on accompagner les
transformations en ayant une vraie
stratégie de la note car on parle de
stratégie
ça ne s'improvise pas être 13 ans
regardent des hommes très en regard de
l'organisation et de la façon dont les
choses se déroulent est un point majeur
avec en plus une vigilance sur le
bien-être et la santé au travail
mais l'exercice continu et là on rentre
sur les managers de proximité
j'ai en train d'accompagner une
organisation 700 managers de proximité
700 patrons de magasins et bah oui
l'organisation a compris qu
effectivement tout se joue en termes
d'engagements sur les managers de
proximité à qui on va redonner de
l'autonomie
un processus est un pouvoir de décision
qui son coeur du réacteur qui sont en
direct avec chacun d'entre vous et
chacun d'entre nous le dernier on est
effectivement en relation avec la
gestion du changement pour toute
personne qui fait partie d'une
organisation grand notre petit d'une
association quelle qu'elle soit à partir
du moment où vous êtes convaincus que
cette organisation a la capacité de vous
accompagner de porter le changement
vous êtes rassurés l'ancrage est bon
vous pouvez vous engager pour conclure
cet stade x je voulais faire une alliée
à une association à une analogie parce
que je travaille souvent que les
symboles avec le jeu d'échecs tout petit
mon père m'a appris à jouer aux échecs
je joue au moins une heure par jour
parfois en ligne contre quelqu'un du
monde entier contre une personne n'a
joueurs contre l'ordinateur avec des
amis une chose est sûre c'est que le jeu
d'échec d'un exercice très intéressant
en lien avec les transformations et
l'engagement
je vous l'expliquais en quelques
secondes dans un jeu déjà il ya
plusieurs pièces il ya le roi le roi
c'est l'organisation
c'est la société c'est celle qu'on doit
protéger on doit protéger rendre pérenne
l'organisation la reine effectivement
c'est la pièce m c'est la pièce
maîtresse est celle qui va donner le
sens la vision qui m en supervision des
projets qui valide et qu'il a donné
effectivement le mouvement et le cap
et puis autour de là il ya plein de
pièces il ya les pions qui vont ouvrir
le jeu qui vont avoir différents rôles
en fonction de leurs cases et puis à
d'autres pièces qui vont s'ajouter le
cavalier km et très vite il commence la
partie très vite y sort rappelez vous il
fonctionne en équerre
qui sort du bois des fois on le voit des
fois on le voit pas c'est une pièce
majeure pour surprendre pour est parfois
là on ne les attend pas et puis à l'oeuf
ou alors l inverse lui très agile ligne
droite raisonne en diagonale très
visible et très efficace et puis arrive
la tour latourelle son rôle c'est
d'arriver en deuxième tour c'est lequel
le dire elle va protéger la stratégie
elle va aider les pièces à pouvoir bien
se positionner et elle va sécuriser
l'organisation même si entre temps il ya
eu des pièces qui ont quitté
l'organisation d'un mesdames et mesdames
et messieurs qu'est ce que je peux vous
souhaitez qu'est ce que je peut nous
souhaiter c'est que à l'image de
l'engagement à l'image de ce jeu
d'échecs
soyez la bonne pièce au bon endroit
soyez la bonne pièce parce
qu'effectivement soyez conscients de
votre engagement métier de là où vous
êtes de ce que vous faites et de là où
vous voulez aller
soyez aussi la bonne pièce est le bon
endroit puisqu'il important d'être dans
l'organisation qui répond à vos attentes
à vos valeurs et aux cycles de demain
merci
[Applaudissements]